they both get to pick but after the sex  it is a hundred women are in control  yeah but also but do you not think that  the the guy from the time that he is the  woman he should have the responsibility  no I I think I think when women have 10  choices we can make to avoid that  situation and men have one there's more  responsibility on us and also but I'm  saying a man has responsibility for life  do I do I think men should just shoot  like I've heard some stories or y'all  don't even pull out I'm like you're  crazy  and I do I do I recommend that no but at  the end of the day we have 10 choices  they have one maybe maybe two if you  glance  women have more responsibility that's  all you're saying okay yeah